[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों एक बार
सभी लोग यह बता दीजिए की मेरी आवाज ए रही
है नहीं ए रही कंफर्म कर दीजिए एक बार चाट
में यस या नो
थैंक यू तो आप सभी का स्वागत युटुब चैनल
पर फिर से आज का जो हमारा टॉपिक है वह
फेसबुक ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस है जो हमारा
नया टॉपिक है तो कंटिन्यू करते हैं किसी
का वेट नहीं करते क्योंकि जिनको आना अभी ए
जाएंगे क्योंकि जो मैं मानता हूं की जो
टाइम पर है वो हर कम टाइम से ही कर पाएगा
अगर जो लेट है तो लेट ही है अपने लाइफ में
भी लेट है चलो स्टार्ट करते हैं तो फेसबुक
ओपन सोशल टेलिजेंस के बड़े में पढ़ने वाले
हैं क्योंकि हमारे पास टाइम कम राहत है
देखो
फेसबुक ओपन सो इंटेलिजेंस
अलसो मोस्ट पॉपुलर सोशल मीडिया सर्विस और
आईटी कूद हेल्प इन गैदरिंग ए डिसेंट
अमाउंट ऑफ इनफॉरमेशन अबाउट टारगेट देखो
सबको पता है फेसबुक भी एक बहुत ही पॉपुलर
सोशल मीडिया सर्विस है या प्लेटफॉर्म है
बोल सकते हैं और ये भी आपको काफी हेल्प कर
सकता है कुछ ऐसी इनफॉरमेशन जो आप किसी
दूसरे अदर प्लेटफॉर्म से क्या नहीं कर
पाते ढूंढ नहीं पाते बाय यूजिंग फेसबुक
क्या होता है जब आप फेसबुक का उसे करके
ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस करते हैं तो कई बार
आपको ऐसे इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिलती है
जिसमें आप खुद ही सरप्राइज होता है क्या
इनफॉरमेशन सही है या राइट है मैं
इनफॉरमेशन
क्या होती है काफी एक्यूरेट इनफॉरमेशन
आपको देखने को मिल जाति है
डेफिनेटली फॉरगॉटेन और गोटन डर एक्टिविटीज
लाइक पोस्ट डेट आईटी पोस्ट पोस्ट आईटी
लाइक पोस्ट आईटी कमेंट पिक्चर्स इट्स शेर
लाइक टैग प्लेस शेर देखो क्या होता है की
जब आप क्या करते हो की फेसबुक किसी को
टारगेट करते हो जिसका फेसबुक अकाउंट है और
काफी टाइम उसने काफी सालों पहले उसने क्या
वो फेसबुक अकाउंट क्रिएट किया था तो इस
कैसे में एक चीज की छोटी होती है क्योंकि
देखो ट्विटर पे हम क्या लिमिटेड ट्वीट ही
करते हैं लिमिटेड भी कम करते हैं लेकिन
फेसबुक क्या है एक सोशल बिल्कुल का रहे थे
जहां पर आप क्या करते हो लाइक कमेंट करते
हो मतलब एक यह तक इसे एक दूसरे इंसान से
जुड़ने की कोशिश करते हैं उनके फीलिंग से
उनके साथ बात करने की उनके साथ फ्रेंड
फ्रेंडशिप करते हो
सारे कम क्या करते थे फेसबुक के थ्रू करते
आप तो एक चीज की शो ये होती है की आप भूल
भी चुके होंगे काफी सालों से अगर फेसबुक
अकाउंट उसे कर रहे हो तो की आपने कब कौन
सी पोस्ट कब की थी इस पोस्ट पर अपने लाइक
किया है किस पोस्ट पर कमेंट किया है कौन
सी पिक्चर कब से किस पिक्चर में आपने
किसको टैग किया है कहां कौन सी जगह की और
क्या उसे पिक्चर में अपना क्या नहीं करना
चाहते थे क्या कर दिया तो वो साड़ी
इनफॉरमेशन आपको याद भी नहीं होगी जो आपने
यहां पर क्या कर दी होगी फेसबुक पर छोड़
दी हुई क्योंकि सालों से आप फेसबुक अकाउंट
को आप उसे करते हो तो उतना कुछ तो अभी वह
साड़ी चीज कभी भी मुझे एवं नहीं रहती
कितने लोगों को अपनी फेसबुक के बड़े में
किसी को याद नहीं राहत नेक्स्ट बात करते
हैं ऑफ कोर्स देवर आर नंबर ऑफ एक्टिविटीज
डेट दे कंपलीटली और गठन अबाउट फ़ॉरगोट
अबाउट पर हैकर्स डेट इनफॉरमेशन वेरी वेरी
इंपॉर्टेंट देखो क्या है की हां तो वही
मैं फाइनली वही बोल रहा हूं की बार-बार की
ऐसे बहुत सारे एक्टिविटीज होगी जो आपके
कंपलीटली फॉरगेट चुके होंगे उनके बड़े में
तो हैकर्स के लिए तो वो साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन
इंपॉर्टेंट होती है तो बाकी दूसरे
प्लेटफॉर्म की तरह भी इसमें भी दो मैथर्ड
होते हैं ओपनटेलिजेंस करने की एक नॉन
टेक्निकल जिससे ट्रेडिशनल मेथड बोलते हैं
एक टेक्निकल जिसमें हैकर्स मेथड बोलते हैं
तो नॉन टेक्निकल ट्रेडिशनल मेथड होता है
की जो सालों से अगर फेसबुक उसे कर रहा है
या फेसबुक को काफी टाइम से उसका यूजर्स है
तो दोस्तों अगर सीमेंट के साथ उसको सर्च
किया जाए तो आप काफी अच्छी इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग कर सकते हो मतलब टेक्निकल मेथड की
हैकर्स मेथड की बात करते हैं उसमें क्या
कुछ ट्रिक टूल्स हम उसे करते हैं उसे
इनफॉरमेशन को गदर करने के लिए इसमें भी हम
ऐसे ही करने वाले हैं तो फेसबुक ओपन
सोटइंटेलीजी
कम है
ट्विटर में 3 दिन
आपको एनालाइज करवा करवा के मैंने वो
डिलीवरी की है जिसको हम दो क्लासेस में
डिलीवर कर सकते थे ट्विटर को भी हमने तीन
क्लासेस में डिलीवर किया है चलो फिर हम
सारे के साथ प्रैक्टिकल करते हैं तो सबसे
पहले बात ये है की आपको क्या करना है की
जो भी आपका फेसबुक अकाउंट है उसमें क्या
करना पड़ेगा आपको लॉगिन करना है क्योंकि
आपको क्या करना लॉगिन क्यों करना पड़ेगा
लॉगिन करने के लिए
लॉगिन इसलिए करना पड़ेगा
तो आप लिमिटेड हो किसी चीज के लिए अगर आप
लिमिटेड हो तो इसका मतलब क्या ज्यादा से
ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन कहते हैं आप नहीं कर
पाओगे तो चलो फिर एक चीज ध्यान रखना हमेशा
की आपको क्या करना है की हमेशा
लाइनेक्स म्युचुअल एनवायरनमेंट में आपको
क्या करना है डेस्कटॉप वर्जन ही उसे करना
है आपके फेसबुक का भी क्योंकि ये काफी
फ्लेक्सिबल होता है फास्ट होता है और ली
रिस्की है मोबाइल से क्योंकि मोबाइल में
हो सकता है की देखो क्या है की अगर आपका
जो टारगेट और ज्यादा ही पैरानॉइड है तो
उसे कैसे में क्या हो सकता है की पैरानॉइड
है तो इसका मतलब उसे कैसे में ये है की
आपने धोखे से बाय चेस किया की मोबाइल में
तो क्या की अगर आपने किसी लाइफ में क्लिक
हो गया दो के दो लाइक हो जाएगा तो कोई
पैनल टारगेट तो क्या करें भाई
कमेंट में तो इस टाइप के सवालों में फस
गया आपको क्या-क्या हो सकता है की आपने
अगर कुछ गलत करने की कोशिश हो जाओगे चलो
फिर हम चलते हैं अपनी मशीन पर चलते हैं जो
हमारी मशीन है ये मैंने लॉगिन किया हुआ है
तो डोंट राइट ऑन दिस
लॉगिन इन में मेरी खुद की है तो इसमें कोई
भी ट्राई नहीं करेगा तो चलो हम करते हैं
तो आज का जो हमारा टारगेट है तो सबसे पहले
मेरा जो टॉपिक रहेगा जो मैं तरीका रहेगा
वह ट्रेडिशनल मेथड रहेगा उसके बाद मैं
क्या हूं हैकर्स मेथड पे जाएंगे
हैकर्स मेथड पर हम जाएंगे तो दिएडिशनल
मेथड में आज हम टारगेट जो लेने वाले हैं
जो हमारा टारगेट रहेगा वो टारगेट क्या है
आपका दूसरा टारगेट है जिसमें मैं किसको
टारगेट ले रहा हूं मेटा मेटा कंपनी को
टारगेट लेने वाला हूं तो मैदा कंपनी को
टारगेट लेने के लिए तो मैं अपना क्या करता
हूं फिर से यस इसको मैं यश कर देता हूं
क्योंकि ऑलरेडी यह कट चुका हूं मैं एक और
नए पेज ओपन कर लेट हूं यस तो कंट्रोल शिव
प्लस प्लस साइज बड़ा दिया तो आज का मेरा
टारगेट क्या है
टारगेट मेरा फोन आज क्योंकि आज थोड़ा सा
नेट ए गया क्योंकि वरना आप बर हो जाओगे
तो सबको पता है की सबसे पहले आपको क्या
करना है फर्स्ट स्टेप आपको हमेशा से पता
है की सबसे पहले आपको ब्राउज़र ओपन करना
है और मैं कंपनी के बड़े में आपको अबाउट
सर्च करना है आपको क्या करना है अबाउट
सर्च करना है अबाउट करता हूं
अबाउट मटर
ए न्यू कंपनी
कुछ देखने को मिल रहा है तो अबाउट में आप
क्या कर सकते हो यहां पर देख सकते हो यहां
पर फेसबुक पेज आपको देखने का कंपनी का
वेबसाइट भी देखने को मिल जाएगी और उसके
फेसबुक पेज ट्विटर पेज भी आपको देखने को
मिल जाएंगे बट एक कम कर दो यहां पे देखने
को मिल रहे हैं मैं क्या करता हूं अभी
मेरे को यहां कुछ इनफॉरमेशन करने कुछ करता
हूं आप जाके कीजिए मैं अभी क्या करता हूं
यहां पे देखो फाइनल अब मुझे ओनली देखो
यहां से जो इसी पेज से क्या इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिलते हैं ये रही
है तो मेरे को यहां पर फाउंडर्स मिल्क मैं
यहां पे कौन से मिल्क फाउंडर्स तो मैं
क्या करता हूं
कॉपी करता हूं और मैं क्या कर लेट हूं तो
आपको एक एडवाइस करूंगा की अगर जब भी आप
क्या करते हो की अगर आप नोट्स मेकिंग कर
रहे हो तो आप सबसे बेस्ट रहेगा गूगल डॉग्स
का उसे करके दी ओ सी एस उसमें क्या होता
है की जो भी लिंक रहते हैं उसमें क्या
होता है की ऐसे कंट्रोल यहां पर
उसे करोगे तो यहां पर क्या है की वो
ऑटोमेटिक लिंक की क्रिएट हो जाते हैं यहां
पर इस पर जैसे क्लिक करोगे तो इसी पेज पर
चला जाएगा फेसबुक के पेज पर या
इंस्टाग्राम के पेज पर चला जाए जॉन से
लिंक आपने यहां पर से किया अभी हमारे पास
क्या है फाउंडर्स हैं मार्क्स अगरबत ये भी
हैं यदि ये कर फाउंडर्स की लिस्ट हमें
देखने को मिली है तो हमने अबाउट से यहां
पे क्या इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग है की अभी ये
कर ली तो इससे ज्यादा और क्या इसमें फरवरी
2004 में कैंब्रिज ये इसके बड़े में
फाउंडेड है इनफॉरमेशन दी हुई है और क्या
है
मार्च अगर क ओके और बस वीडियो इनफॉरमेशन
भी एंड्रयू में
इनफॉरमेशन भी हमें देखने को मिल रही है
कॉपी करता हूं मैं
क्या करता हूं अभी
कंट्रोल देखने को मिल रहे हैं चलो अब बात
करते हैं मार्क्स
जो है एक मिनट कंट्रोल भी मार्ग ओके मैं
सी यू मिल गया अब मैं क्या करता हूं एक
बार अब मैं फेसबुक पेज पर जाता हूं मेरा
फेसबुक पेज पर जाता हूं और मैंने क्या मैं
क्या करता हूं यहां पर सर्च करता हूं
क्योंकि यहां पर सर्च बार कहां पर सबसे
ऊपर ये सर्च बार आपको तो मैं क्या करता
हूं सर्च बार में क्या करता हूं मेटा
मैंने यहां पर क्या किया मेटा सर्च किया
पापा आपको देखने को मिल जाएगा देखिए की अब
ये देखो ये फेशियल तीन जो फैसिलिटी आपको
देखने को मिलती है यहां पे देखो ये इतने
सारे ऑप्शंस देखने को मोबाइल्स में क्या
है की ये इतने सारे ऑप्शन देखने को जरूर
मिलेंगे लेकिन आपका बहुत प्रॉब्लम होती है
यहां पे देखो डेस्कटॉप वर्जन में काफी
मजेदार इनफॉरमेशन मिलती है और काफी कुछ आप
कलेक्ट भी कर सकते हो इजी कर सकते हो देखो
यहां पर जो पोस्ट तो आपको क्या करना है
आपको पहले से पता है ट्रेडिशनल मेथड में
ऑलरेडी आपने कहां से शिखा था मैंने आपको
बताया था ट्विटर गेम में तो आपको क्या
करना है किसी भी टाइप को नहीं छोड़ना हर
टाइप पर हर इमेज पे हर वीडियो पे
जैसे की लाइक है यहां पर भी फ्रेंड्स हैं
कमेंट्स हैं लाइक है हर चीज को क्या करना
है जाना है और पता करना है क्या चीज आप
यहां ओपन करके देखा हूं देखो यहां पर बहुत
कुछ देखने को मिल रहा है अभी जैसे की मैं
यहां पर क्या पोस्ट में देखने को यहां पर
जो था तो पोस्ट में देखने को मिल सकता है
और ये काफी क्या है एडवांस सच में देखने
मिला है देखो यहां पर यहां पर क्या
डिस्टेंस पोस्ट स्टोन कर सकते हो पोस्ट यू
हैव सीन इस को ऑन कर सकते हो डेट पोस्ट
अगर आप क्या है अकॉर्डिंग तू डेट देखना
चाहते हैं 2004 से ऐसे वाली देखना चाहते
वो भी देख सकते हो उसके पीपल पीपल जाओगे
तो यहां पे देख सकते हो ये देख तो इस तरह
के आपको पता है क्योंकि आप सालों से
फेसबुक उसे कर रहे हो तो आपको अच्छे से
पता किया जनरल फिल्ट्रेशन कैसे किया जाता
है जनरल आपको सर्चिंग कैसे की जाति है
फोटोस में जाके चेक कर सकते हो अभी आप
देखो फोटोस में क्या देखने को मिल रहा है
ओनली इसकी शब्द रिलेटेड वीडियो और वीडियो
में भी आप क्या कर रहे हैं
डेट पोस्टेड भी कर सकते हो लाइव और लाइव
मार्केट प्लेस में जाके देख सकते हो की
मार्केट प्लेस में क्या देख रहे हो मिल
रहा है देखो तो काफी कुछ है जो आपके यहां
पर देख सकते हो तो अपना क्या करता हूं आप
कैसे चला हूं बैक होम पे चला हूं मैं
तो चलो तो अभी इधर
मटर किया मैंने फिर से सर्च करता हूं और
यहां पर क्या है मैं पेज पर जाता हूं पेज
पर देखा हूं
बिजनेस मेटाफोर क और इंजीनियरिंग अप मटर
तो काफी कुछ मेटाफोर मीडियम और मेटा सोशल
इंपैक्ट मेटाफोर डेवलप पर एजुकेशन काफी
देख रहे हो तो मिल रहा है तो मैं क्या
करता देखो अब यहां पर क्लिक करता हूं यहां
देखो पेज इंटरनेट कंपनी है मेटल हेल्पिंग
बिल ए फ्यूचर वेयर पीपल हैव मोर वे तू
प्ले और कनेक्ट इन फटाफट ओके mater.com
मैं आपको 4.2 मिलियन फॉलोअर्स ओके मैं
इसको का देता हूं ओपन करता हूं तो ये है
आपकी माता कंपनी इसके बड़े में मुझे क्या
करना है इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करनी है अब
मैंने क्या कर दिया की मैंने इसके वेब पेज
पर ए गया तो यहां पर क्या करना है मुझे
इंट्रो क्षेत्र में जाना है इंट्रो
क्षेत्र में जितनी इनफॉरमेशन मैंने देखने
को मिल रही है ये देख रहे हो यहां पर क्या
है इंटरनेट कंपनी है mater.com ये क्या है
इसका ओपन न्यू तब कर देता हूं देखने को
मिल रहा है और यहां पर क्या है ये फोटो
देखने को मिल रहे हैं फोटोस पर क्लिक करता
हूं अगर किसी भी फोटो पर क्लिक करता हूं
देखिए यहां पर कोई भी फोटो को क्लिक करता
हूं यहां पर देखो इसके ऊपर लाइक कमेंट सब
कुछ आपको देखने को मिल जाएगा एवं देखो आप
क्या करता की ये देखो ये आप डेस्कटॉप
वर्जन है फायदा की आपने क्या-क्या यहां पर
ओनली हावर किया और यहां पर देखो अगर थोड़े
थोड़े होंगे तो आपको क्या है इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिल जाएगी ज्यादा कम देखने
में कर सकते हो अगर ज्यादा है तो आप क्या
है क्लिक कर सकते हैं यहां पर जैसे आपने
क्लिक किया तो यहां साड़ी वो इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिल जाएगी जितने भी जिन्होंने
इनको क्या किया है लाइक किया है या कमेंट
किया है लाइक वाले में ये थम्स अप वाले की
इनफॉरमेशन ये है और यह हार्ट वाले इमोजी
हरे की इमोजी के अकॉर्डिंग क्या कर सकते
हो आप कैलकुलेट ही फॉर्मेशन देख सकते हो
यहां पर आपने देखने को मिल रही है एवं
यहां पे देख सकते हो किसने किया ये इसके
अकॉर्डिंग देखने को मिलेगी यहां पर
कमेंट्स देख सकते हो कमेंट करके देख तो ये
साड़ी आप इनफॉरमेशन यहां पर धीरे डाउट कर
सकते हो तो मैं यहां पर कुछ नहीं करके
दिखा रहा था आपको क्योंकि ये आपको खुद से
ही करना है अब उसके बाद क्या करना है यहां
पर और ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन तक देखने को मिल
नहीं रही और क्या कर रहा हूं मैं आप अबाउट
में जाता हूं अबाउट में क्या-क्या
इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल रही है तो अबाउट
में क्या इंटरनेट कंपनी है वेबसाइट देखने
को हमें मिल गई है रेल्स ओके ये क्या है
कांटेक्ट और बेसिक इनफॉरमेशन देखिए इसके
बड़े में कुछ इंटरनेट कंपनी ये है पेज
ट्रांसमिशन
तू हेल्प यू अंडरस्टैंड डी परपज ऑफ दिस
पेज ये पेज आईडी है इसकी
फर्स्ट अप्रैल 2020 ओके एडमिन इनफॉरमेशन
दे हैव परमिशन तो पोस्ट कंटेंट कमेंट्स
ओके दिस पेज रनिंग और ओके यहां पर देखो
काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिल
जाएगी अगर देखोगे तो पीपल हूं मैनेज दिस
पेज देखो प्राइमरी कंट्रीज और ये इंक्लूड
इंडिया 15th से मोर इनफॉरमेशन जर्मनी वन
पीपल कंट्री
देखने को मिल रही है अब यहां देखो इंटरनेट
पे जो ये सर कम क्या है आपको ही करना है
और इसके बाद क्या है इसमें और कुछ देखने
को मिल रहा है सी जो में यहां पर
मेंशन मेंशन में देखिए क्या है नथिंग
नथिंग
जाके देख सकते हो यहां पर बैठा के बड़े
में तो ये आपको पता था एक बार आप क्या
करना है देखो ये अगर आपने कंपनी के वेब
पेज से अगर जितने भी इनफॉरमेशन आप कलेक्ट
कर का रहे हो तो कर लीजिए उसके बाद अब मैं
क्या करता हूं उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं
इंडिविजुअल प्रोफाइल को क्या करते हैं
टारगेट करते हैं अभी हमारे परसेंटेज में
प्रोफाइल क्या है इंडिविजुअल
प्रोफाइल्स को देख लिया उसके बाद आपको
क्या करना है इंडिविजुअल प्रोफाइल पे जाना
है तो अब ये देखो ये है मार्क जुकरबर्ग की
क्या है प्रोफाइल देखने को मिल रहे हो की
देखो यहां पर अगर इनके पेज पे चलते हैं तो
फिर क्योंकि हर एक टाइप को यहां भी ओपन
करके देखना
ओपन करके देखना है की यहां पर क्या-क्या
देखने को मिल रहा है आपको अब देखो आलस हैं
यहां पे देख के मार्क्स अग्रवाल देखने को
मिल रही है
लोगों
को ऑलवेज ओपन यह देखो अब अगर मैं यहां पर
ये भी हो शक्ति है
अगर मैं इसको देखूं और क्या ये
काफी देखने को मिलते रहे क्या आपको
प्रोफाइल देखने को कब है जुलाई यहां पर
क्या इन्होंने पोस्ट की है लेटेस्ट पोस्ट
की हुई है 18 जुलाई इतना टाइम पर तो हम
इसको क्या करते हैं ओपन करते हैं न्यू तब
में अब इनके यहां हमारे पास पेज ए गया
प्रोफाइल पेज ए गया
इनके बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन कैसे करते हैं
देखो हमारे पास क्या फाउंडर हैं
ये क्या चीज है ये क्या है नॉन प्रॉफिट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन बिल्डिंग जस्ट और हेल्दी
फ्यूचर पर एवरीवन यह क्या एक्चुअल में अगर
देखोगे तो ये इनकी वाइफ की एक कंपनी है जो
इनकी वाइफ है
और ये क्या है ये इनकी कंपनी है तो हम
क्या करें साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन कॉपी करते हैं
और क्या करते हैं
कंट्रोल उसके बाद क्या करते हो कॉपी और
अपने सारे इनफॉरमेशन
है ये है
ओके उसके बाद नेक्स्ट यहां पर ओके यस यस
मिलती है तभी ये हमारे पास इनफॉरमेशन के
बड़े में और क्या करते हैं इनके प्रोफाइल
की इन्होंने 644 भेजो हुआ है अबाउट में
जाकर देखिए अबाउट मोर करके देखने को मिल
रहा है देखो
वर्कशीट कंप्यूटर साइंस और टेक्नोलॉजी
लीव्स इनका लोकेशन भी देखने को मिल रही है
और फ्रॉम कहां से है और मैरिड तू शादी की
है उसके बाद क और एजुकेशन आपको देखने को
मिल रही है देखो ये साड़ी चीज अब सब कुछ
इनफॉरमेशन क्या कर सकते हो कंट्रोल सी और
क्या करना है
अपने पास रखिए
तो काफी अभी क्या यहां पर क्या है थोड़ा
प्रॉब्लम है इनफॉरमेशन जो वो करने में
जितनी भी आपने कलेक्ट की है अभी मैं इसको
रिमूव कर रहा हूं वैसे क्योंकि साड़ी
साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन अभी हम कलेक्ट करने में
क्या की अगर मैं इसको अगर बटर तरीके से
दिखता हूं उसमें क्लिक करके आपको क्या नाम
है
गूगल डॉग्स में तो काफी अच्छा राहत है तो
ये साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन आपको क्या करना है
देखो हाय स्कूल उसके बाद क्या है प्लेस
लाइव ये रहे उसके कांटेक्ट और बेसिक
इनफॉरमेशन आपके इनको देखने को मिल रहा है
बट दें का है 14 में 1984th एयर इंग्लिश
लैंग्वेज मेडियन चाइनीस और उसके बाद क्या
फैमिली रिलेशनशिप आपको देखना है यदि उसके
बाद डीटेल्स अबाउट मार्क एन के बड़े में
खुद के बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन फेवरेट इनकी
क्या है लाइव इवेंट भी देख सकते हो आप
इनके इनको क्या-क्या पसंद है तो 15 12 10
2019 स्टार्टड आज ओके तो ये देखिए यहां पर
ए गया मैं इसको क्या करता हूं अगर मैं कल
करता हूं
ओके तो काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को
क्या लगता है मिल सकता है चलो चलो बैक बैक
इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिल रही है अभी
क्या एक और चीज ध्यान रखना की जब भी क्या
करते हो आप किसी भी तरह पर्सनल प्रोफाइल
को टारगेट करने की कोशिश करते हैं आपको
क्या करना है तो एक बार आपको क्या चेक कर
लेना जो इनका ये जो प्रोफाइल पिक्चर है
क्या वो क्लिक केवल है नोट क्लिक केवल अगर
क्लिक केवल है तो आपको क्या करना है की अब
इस पर क्लिक करना आप देखो आपने इसके ऊपर
क्लिक किया तो देखो यहां पर आपको वो बहुत
साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल जाएगी यहां
पे देखो 2.8 मिलियन फूल ओवर हैं यहां पे
वो लिस्ट है साड़ी की साड़ी लाइक कमेंट
किया है तो यहां भी काफी इनफॉरमेशन आप
देखो और कब ये पिक्चर इन्होंने इसके ऊपर
फेसबुक के ऊपर डाली थी 18 अक्टूबर 2022 को
ये फेसबुक के ऊपर उन्होंने कहा है आपने
पेज पे राखी हुई है देखो यहां पर
प्लीज गिव मी ब्लूटूथ आई डोंट हैव
पेरेंट्स ओके तो ये काफी कुछ इन्होंने
इनफॉरमेशन यहां पर है ये आपका कम है
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग का नाम मैं क्या करता
हूं बैक जाता हूं उसके बाद क्या यहां पर
ये जो साइड प्रोफाइल है जो कर पिक्चर है
उसको भी हम क्या करते हैं ओपन करते हैं और
इससे रिलेटेड आपका हो गया देखो ये 28 जून
2016 को ये ये पिक्चर्स ठीक है अपडेटेड
विद तू बिलियन पीपल डी वर्ल्ड इसे एन
लिटिल ब्राइटों यहां पे ये इनफॉरमेशन एक
501 के इन्होंने क्या है इस पे इनके क्या
है इस पिक्चर्स के बेसिस पर देखो उन्हें
देखो ये तो ये आपको देखने को मिल रहा है
काफी इनफॉरमेशन कर रहे हो उसके बाद देखो
फ्रेंड्स में देखेंगे क्या इनको फ्रेंड
लिस्ट सॉरी है ये इनके फॉलोअर्स हैं इनके
फॉलोअर्स हैं आपको देखने को मिल रहे हैं
तो काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने
फॉलोअर्स हैं इनके जो फॉलो करते हैं और
फोटोस ये देखो
फोटोस में वीडियो में
रियल में और
मोर इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिल रही है यहां पर तो काफी कुछ
आपको इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल रही है ये
आपका कम है गदर करना है तो मैंने क्या
करना है आपको बता दिया की उसके बाद क्या
आपको हर एक चीज को चेक करना है तो आपको
पता चल गया देखो चीज होती है देखो आप क्या
प्रोफाइल ओपन की हुई है जो भी प्रोफाइल
ओपन किया तो यहां पर भी आपको क्या एक
प्रोफाइल के अंदर भी क्या है की
1 मिनट
जो प्रोफाइल से फेसबुक में कोई चीज होती
है जो प्रोफाइल है उसे प्रोफाइल के अंदर
भी क्या एक सर्च फिल्टर है अब जब यहां पर
सर्च फिल्टर करोगे तो आपको अगर कोई कीवर्ड
याद है इंसुलेटेड अगर आपको लगता है कोई
कीबोर्ड आपको याद है आपने आपने कहानी
कीबोर्ड के बड़े में पता है इसे इनफॉरमेशन
के दौरान या कोई फ्रेंड्स को इनके लिस्ट
में पता करना चाहते हो की क्या कोई
फ्रेंड्स है यार इनकी लिस्ट में आप कोई
फॉलोअर्स है नहीं है वो साड़ी चीज आप यहां
पर क्या कर सकते हो सर्च कर सकते हो ये
क्या है इस इंडिविजुअल पेज का सर्च बार है
तो आप ओनली जो भी यहां पर सर्च करोगे
कीबोर्ड वो आपको यहां पर देखो मैं फेसबुक
की सर्च करता हूं फेसबुक या मटर सर्च कर
रहा हूं मेंट ही सर्च करता हूं यहां पर
मटर सर्च करता हूं तो इंटर किया मैंने
जो मैंने सर्च किया था यह ओनली इसी
प्रोफाइल के अंदर ही सर सर्च रिजल्ट आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है तो यह था तो एक चीज
हमेशा ध्यान रखना एक और चीज हम आपको बता
देता हूं बैक करता हूं
आपको हमेशा कहना वीडियो साड़ी वीडियो
देखनी है और वो वीडियो स्पेशली देखनी है
जिसमें टारगेट क्या कर रहा था आपका बातें
कर रहा है जो टारगेट क्या कर रहा है खुद
से बातें कर रहा है क्योंकि हो सकता है की
जब वो आपके से कुछ शेर कर रहा हो तो उससे
कुछ ऐसे इनफॉरमेशन लीकेज हो जाए बोलते हो
तो आपके लिए हेल्पफुल हो इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग में अभी यहां पर बहुत साड़ी
वीडियो मिलेगी देखो एक चीज ध्यान रखना मैं
आपको बता देता हूं की मैं चाहे कोई भी
पढ़ाया कोई भी कुछ करें एक किसी भी एक
लेक्चर के ड्यूरेशन में 1 घंटे 2 घंटे
ड्यूरेशन में किसी भी एक प्रोफाइल के बड़े
में आप ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन नहीं निकाल सकते
इस ड्यूरेशन के बीच में आप अगर पहले से ही
आपने अगर मीना तक या 15 दिन तक किसी
पर्टिकुलर पे इनफॉरमेशन नहीं की होगी तो
एक
छोटे से एक घंटे गया दो घंटे के लेक्चर
में आप किसी भी टारगेट के ऊपर इनफॉरमेशन
नहीं कर सकते बट हम क्या करना आपको ट्रिक
बता सकते हैं टिप्स दे सकते हैं आपको ऐसे
अप्रोच करना है बाकी इनफॉरमेशन कहते हैं
आपको खुद को करना होगा अगर मैं आपके सामने
अगर मैं एक-एक चीज को अगर यहां पर एक-एक
पोस्ट को देखूंगा एक-एक चीज को लिंक करने
की कोशिश करो तो मैं आपको ओनली फेसबुक के
ऊपर शो इंटेलिजेंस इनफॉरमेशन करके दिखता
हूं 15 प्लस डेज में आपको लगाऊंगा अभी तो
दो तीन तीन कर कर घंटे अगर हम कंटिन्यू
करेंगे तो लाइव क्लास में जब भी जा के हम
वो इनफॉरमेशन नहीं कर पे क्योंकि साड़ी
चीज लाइव क्लास में बताना वेरी टिपिकल का
तो इसलिए मैं क्या का रहा हूं आपको सब
कच्चाब कर रहा हूं चीजों के साथ क्योंकि
मैं ट्विटर में इतना टाइम दिया है तो
फेसबुक में इतना टाइम देने को फायदा नहीं
है क्योंकि आप बर हो जाओगे
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो तो अभी
इसमें भी क्या है की चलो आपको पता चल गया
इसमें होम पर जाता हूं मैं तो इसमें भी
क्या होता है की आप क्या कर सकते हो की आप
उन्हें जब वहां पर उसे किया था ना जो सर्च
बार में कुछ ट्रिक उसे की हुई थी यहां पर
साड़ी तो कम नहीं करती बट क्या कुछ कम
करती है तो यहां पर कौन सी ट्रिक हैं वो
एग्जांपल यहां पर स्टार कम करता है स्टार
का कम क्या करता है पर एग्जांपल अभी गेम
मैंने क्या कर दिया की मार्क किया और उसके
बाद मैंने क्या किया स्टार्ट कर दिया मार
दिया स्टार क्या कर देगा आपको पता है की
स्टार क्या कम करता है तो इस तरीके से
मार्च उसके बाद कुछ भी हो सकता है सच
एनीथिंग
आफ्टर मार्क ओके तो यह है अगेन यहां पे आप
क्या करना चाहते हो अगर आपको की फैमिली की
डीटेल्स देखना चाहते हो आपको सबका पता है
की मार्क जुकरबर्ग जाकर भर के इनका क्या
है
सरनेम तो सरनेम क्या किया क्योंकि फैमिली
मेंबर्स को फाइंड आउट करना है रिलेटिव ऑफ
फाइंड आउट करना है तो आपको क्या करना
पड़ेगा
तो आप क्या कर सकते हो तार लगा सकते हो
तार उसके बाद क्या करोगे
तो आपको देखने को मिल जाएगी आगे कुछ भी हो
लेकिन लास्ट में जा कर बोल होना चाहिए
यहां पे काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन आपको ग्रुप
देखने को मिलेंगे फोटोस है ये देखो ये
काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल जाएगी
आपको एक चीज ध्यान रखना जब भी आप क्या
करते हो कोई भी यहां पर सर्च ऑपरेशन
परफॉर्म कर देना
परफॉर्म करने के बाद यहां पर रिलेटेड सब
चीज आता है ना ये काफी हेल्पफुल होती है
काफी हेल्पफुल होता है क्योंकि लेटेस्ट सर
चीज क्या ए जाएगी किसी ना किसी ने तो यहां
पर सर्च किया है ऐसे की शब्द को भी सर्च
किया है आपको क्या करना है जितने भी किसी
भी सर्च थ्योरी के बाद आपको जो भी रिलेटिव
समझते हैं सबको क्या करना है आपको सर्च
करके देखना है ताकि वहां पर कई बार आपको
क्या कर सकता है की आप अपनी सर्च इंजन के
थ्रू इनफॉरमेशन के अध्ययन करने की कोशिश
कर रहे हो लेकिन आप जी तरीके से सर्च करने
को उससे नहीं मिला लेकिन यहां पर जो उसने
रिलेटिव सच दिखाए उसके आपको इनफॉरमेशन
देखना है तो मिल जाए देखो उसके बेसिकली
आपको इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल जाए ऐसे तो
ऐसे इस तरीके से आप भी क्या कर सकते हो
लेट्यूस का भी काफी अच्छे तरीके से उसे कर
सकते हो उसके बाद आप क्या कर सकते हो पर
एग्जांपल की ओनली अब क्या कर सकते हो मैं
चाहता हूं की मार्क
जेड यू सी के चक्कर मार्ग उसके बाद मैं
देखना चाहता हूं ओनली पिक्चर्स पिक्चर्स
ही देखने को मिले तो ओके ओनली पिक्चर
चाहिए आपको देखने को मिलेगी पोस्ट ओनली
पिक्चर्स वाले रिलेटेड इनफॉरमेशन ओनली
पिक्चर सी देखने को मिलेगी अगर आप क्या
चाहते हो ओन्ली यहां पर पिक्चर के अलावा
ओनली आप चाहते हो की फोटोस
पिक्चर्स फोटोस वीडियो देखो अब थोड़ा सा
डिफरेंट डिफरेंट रिजल्ट है देखो डिफरेंट
रिजल्ट्स है तो ये सारे कीवर्ड्स आपको
देखो जितने पॉसिबल कीवर्ड्स आपको पता है
सारे के सारे सर्च करके देख लेना है जितने
भी आपको लगता है की ये साड़ी मुझे सर्च
करना चाहिए फोटोस हो गया उसके बाद आप
वीडियो के बेसिस भी कर सकते हो वे आई दी ओ
एफ वीडियो ओनली तो वीडियो के बेसिस पे
क्या कर सकते क्योंकि आगे क्या है फर्स्ट
नाम लास्ट नाम उसके बाद मैंने कोई भी
कीवर्ड दे दी है देखो यहां पर काफी कुछ
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है ये वीडियो है
साड़ी ओनली क्योंकि जो यूजर्स नाम है
मार्क्स जगह पर आपको देखने को मिल रहे हैं
यहां पर तो यहां पर ये रहा वीडियो तो ये
चीज है उसके बाद क्या है की आपको ये मैंने
बता दिया रिलेटेड को आपको ध्यान में रखना
है उसके बाद क्या आएगी इस तरीके से आप
सर्चिंग परफॉर्म कर सकते हो उसके बाद इसके
बाद कोई भी उसे कर सकते हो स्टार उसे कर
सकते हो और और ऑपरेटर भी यहां पे कम करता
है और ऑपरेटर भी यहां पे अच्छे से कम करते
हैं कैसे पर एग्जांपल मैं क्या चाहता हूं
मटर कर दिया मैंने उसके बाद यहां पर और कर
सकते हो किस तरीके से आप उसे कर सकते हो
देखो और यहां पर आपको क्या करना है जब भी
आप और लॉजिक परफॉर्म कर रहे हो लॉजिक
परफॉर्म कर रहे हैं तो आप क्या करना है
लॉजिक इसमें दोनों तरीके से आपको उसे करना
है एक तो ये वाला और ऑपरेटर आपको उसे करके
देखना है और उसके बाद ये भी आपको ए एचडी
दोनों ही परफॉर्म करके देखना
क्योंकि कई बार दोनों में कैसे में क्या
है डिफरेंट आपको देखने को मिलेंगे देखना
उसके बाद क्या है
या तो आपको एक और इस तरीके से लिख सकता
हूं आपको पता है और एक तरीके से सॉरी और
एक और इस तरीके से भी लिख सकते हो लॉजिक
तो आप ये दोनों परफॉर्म करके देखना है
आपको तो मैं दोनों ही परफॉर्म करके आपको
दिखा देता हूं रिजल्ट देखना रिजल्ट का
डिफाइन मटर और
ये सबको पता है की और ऑपरेटर कैसे कम करता
है और ऑपरेटर कैसे कम करता है मैं इसको
अभी आपको रिपीट नहीं करूंगा अगर कोई
डायरेक्टली हमारी वीडियो देखने के लिए आया
है तो वो क्या उसको क्या करना है ट्विटर
ओपन सोशल टेलिजेंस की सेकंड या सेकंड दे
वाले जो वीडियो है उसको देख लेना है जो
हमारे युटुब चैनल पर है तो वहां से आप
आइडिया ले सकते हो की और और लॉजिक कैसे कम
करता है अब इतना डीटेल्स इसमें हम नहीं
बातें करेंगे तो मेटा उसके बाद मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं यहां पर मैंने किया जकरबर्ग को
मैंने किया के उस के जब देखा उसके बाद
इंटर कर दिया अब ये उन साड़ी पोस्ट को या
उन साड़ी चीजों को फाइंड आउट करके देगा
जिसमें दोनों ही होंगे मेटल देखिए ये सारे
सारे एक इस तरीके से और है दूसरा आप क्या
कर सकते हो यहां पर इस और की जगह आप कैसे
लिख सकते हो ये इस तरीके से आप क्या कर
सकते हो सर्च कर सकते हो
सर्च कर सकते हो यहां पे देखना है यहां पे
थोड़ा डिफरेंट रीजंस आपको देखने को
मिलेंगे देखना एक और यहां पे ये
फाइव नोट वर्किंग
इस कैसे में थोड़े से डिफरेंट रिजल्ट आपको
देखने को मिल रहे हैं अभी आपको और भी है
और कभी आपको पता है या तो दोनों ही होना
चाहिए या इनमें से कोई भी एक भी होगा तो
चलेगा एक इस तरीके से भी आप कर सकते हो और
के लिए
इस तरीके से भैया कर सकते हो
यहां पर पर एग्जांपल
इनकी जो लोकेशन थी ये भी कर सकता हूं मैं
और देखो इस पर्टिकुलर लोकेशन के आधार पर
क्या इनफॉरमेशन मिल जाएगी अगर हमें इस और
की जगह मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं और भी कर
सकता हूं तो यह भी आपको देखने को मिल
जाएगा
तो यह साड़ी आपको देखना पड़ेगा
फोटोस अलोन मास वीडियो एफबी फाउंडर और
सीईओ ऐसे भी आप क्या कर सकते हो इससे जा
के आप साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो
क्योंकि आपको पता है इसके बेसिस पे आपको
क्या है बहुत साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन हो सकता है
की आपको इनके फ्रेंड्स देखने को मिले
फैमिलीज देखने को मिल जाए यहां पर क्लोज
फ्रेंड देखने को मिल जाए या किस-किस भारत
में उन्होंने किस-किस पोस्ट में किसको टैग
किया आपको सबको पता है देखो आप लोगों को
फेसबुक उसे करनी है करनी आई है तो आपको भी
पता है जब भी आप क्या करते हो फेसबुक पे
उसे करते हो किसके साथ अगर टैग करते हो
टैग किसको करते हो ऐसे ही बेवड़े तो किसी
को टैग कर नहीं देते हो तो टैग किसको करते
हो अपने फ्रेंड्स को करते हैं अपने क्लोज
फ्रेंड को करते हो इस को ट्रैक करते हैं
अपने फैमिली मेंबर को टैग करते हो तभी तो
टैग करते हो या कमेंट किसी पर करते हो आप
बेवकूफ डायरेक्टली कमेंट तो नहीं करते या
तो उसको आप जानते हो या तो उसमें इंटरेस्ट
है लाइक करते हो यही चीज हैं आप किसी भी
कमेंट करो अपनी इमोशंस या अपने विचार या
जो भी आपके मां में हो क्या करते हो आप
वहां पर रिप्रेजेंट करते हो तो ये साड़ी
चीज होती है इन्हीं चीजों को आपको क्या
करना है आम सेंस को उसे करते हो हैकर मन
के साथ इनफॉरमेशन करनी है तो यही साड़ी
चीज आपको देखने को मिल रही है तो ये था
आपका जनरल
मैंने क्या किया की यहां पर की कोई भी
प्रोफाइल अभी यहां पर इनके फ्रेंड्स देखने
को मिले नहीं आपको वहां से अगर बाल की
प्रोफाइल से हमारे पास एक मिनट
डिलीट करता हूं टेंडर
कुछ भी शो नहीं कर रहा बस ओन्ली शो कर रहा
है तो फ्रेंड्स मैं अलग से आते हैं कभी भी
आपने फेसबुक वगैरा ऐसा कुछ काफी टाइम से
मैंने उसे नहीं किया कुछ चेंज हो गया था
आई एम सॉरी पर डेट बट मुझे ज्यादा लगता है
फ्रेंड्स लिस्ट अलग होती है इन्होंने क्या
फ्रेंड रिक्वेस्ट किया हुआ है
की फ्रेंड्स मैं आपको जो भी इनफॉरमेशन
मिलेगा आपको क्या करना है कभी भी फ्रेंड
लिस्ट को भूलना मत डॉ करना आपके पास दो
सुनिए तो एक-एक फ्रेंड को के ऊपर जाइए हाल
कीजिए उसको कॉपी कीजिए ये आप क्या
डायरेक्टली सभी को कंट्रोल कर सकते हो या
ऐसे क्या कर सकते हो सभी को सिलेक्ट कर
सकते हो उसके बाद कंट्रोल भी कर सकते हो
इस तरीके से आप क्या करते हो कभी भी पूरे
पूरे फ्रेंड लिस्ट को आपको क्या करना है
ग्रैब करना है कभी भी उसको छोड़ना नहीं है
दूसरा एक और चीज होती है एक और चीज बताता
हूं आपको अगर आपको क्या करना है टारगेट की
जो जो आपका जो टारगेट अकाउंट है टारगेट
अकाउंट कौन सा यही है मार्कर क है अगर
मुझे इसका ये की उन्होंने कम यह क्रिएट की
है क्रिएशन डेट देखनी है तो आप दो जगह से
क्रिएशन डेट पता कर सकते हैं या तो अबाउट
में जाओगे और देखो एग्जैक्ट डेट का ऐसा
कोई टूल नहीं है की एग्जैक्ट डेट निकाल
पाएगी एग्जैक्ट ये प्रोफाइल कब क्रिएट
किया की होगी फेसबुक की बट लाइव इवेंट पर
जाते हैं क्या होता है की आप जब भी क्या
करते हो ये जब भी आप फेसबुक रजिस्टर करते
हो कुछ भी करते हो तो आप क्या करते हो की
आप जब भी उसमें कुछ अपडेट करते हो तो आप
इस हिसाब से करते हो तो हम आइडिया ले सकते
हैं की सबसे पहले क्या है 1998 की जो
इन्होंने क्या किया प्रोफाइल अपडेट की हुई
है इसका मतलब क्या है की हम आयरन ले सकते
हैं या तो 1997 या 1998 इसी टाइम पे
इन्होंने क्या की होगी ये प्रोफाइल अपडेट
की इसी टाइम पर प्रोफाइल क्या होगी
उन्होंने की होगी तो दूसरा कहां से आप
इनफॉरमेशन कैसे नहीं कर सकते हो की यह कौन
सी ये पर एग्जांपल ग्रेट की होगी तो आपको
क्या करना है अभी पोस्ट पर जाना है इनके
तो पोस्ट पर जाना ही है एक कम करते हैं
इनकी प्रोफाइल फाइल हमारे पास ओके और यहां
पर क्या देखने को मिल रहा है
पर एग्जांपल
प्रोफाइल पर तो मार्केट प्लेस पर जाना है
मैं कम करता हूं बैक जाता हूं यहां पर यह
रहा
हूं देखना कोई भी मार्केटप्लेस नहीं है
अगर इन्होंने क्या है की मार्केट प्लेस का
मतलब क्या होता है की उन्होंने कोई भी
प्रोडक्ट क्या लॉन्च किया होगा कुछ
प्रोडक्ट फाउंड किया उन्होंने क्या किया
यहां पर मार्केट प्लेस में जाके क्रिएट
किया होगा मार्क्स अग्रवाल ने तो जब
उन्होंने वो क्रिएट किया होगा तो वहां पे
क्या हो गए एक इनफॉरमेशन शो कर रहा होगा
की ये फेसबुक में इन्होंने कब जॉइन किया
था इस देखिए यहां भी आपको क्या का सकता है
की जॉइनिंग अकाउंट क्रिएशन जो डेट है जॉइन
जॉइनिंग डेट है फेसबुक के ऊपर वो आपको रफ
आइडिया आपको मिल जाएगा तो ये एक तरीका था
की इंडिविजुअल प्रोफाइल को क्या कर सकते
हो टारगेट कर सकते हो तो अभी एक कम करता
हूं की अभी तक तो हम ट्रेडीशन मेथड में कम
कर रहे हैं
ट्रेडिशनल मेथड के साथ ही हम कम कर रहे
हैं अब हम धीरे-धीरे
मेथड ट्रेडिशनल मेथड में मैंने
जल्दी-जल्दी इसलिए बताया क्योंकि आपको पता
है की आपको क्या करना है आपको इतना आइडिया
है की आपको क्या करना है अब ये आपके हाथ
में आप कैसे इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करोगे मेरा
क्या मेरे को क्या करना है बस आपको बताना
है की आप ऐसे ऐसे चीजों को चेक कर सकते
हैं लेकिन एक चीज ध्यान में रखना किसी भी
सिंगल टैब को आपको छोड़ना नहीं है हर एक
टाइप पे जाना है हर एक चीज को आपको चेक
करना है अब बात करते हैं हम टेक्निकल मेथड
कैसे उसे करते हैं देखो जब भी आप क्या
करते हो टारगेट टारगेट जो भी होता है उसके
बड़े में आपके पास है तो सबसे ज्यादा दो
चीज पता करने की कोशिश करते हो दो
इंपॉर्टेंट इनफॉरमेशन आप फाइंड आउट करने
की कोशिश करते हो एक तो उसका यूजर नाम
आपको पता होना चाहिए दूसरा आप क्या करते
हैं उसकी यूजर आए क्योंकि कई जगह जब आप
कुछ टूल्स उसे करोगे तो आप उसे टूल्स में
क्या करना आपको यूजर आईडी डालनी पड़ती है
इस के बेस पर आप रिजल्ट काफी एक्यूरेट
इनफॉरमेशन गेट आउट कर पाते हो पार्टिकल
प्रोफाइल से दूसरा यार आपको यूजर नाम
बताना चाहिए अब देखो एक तो ये जो नाम आपको
कैसे देखने को मिल रहा है देखो अब ये है
की यहां पर मैंने क्या किया पोस्ट पे किया
अब मैं यहां पर देख रहा हूं तो ये मार्क्स
अगर क है ये इनका फूल नाम फर्स्ट नाम
लेकिन अगर आपको यूजर नाम देखना तो आपको
यूआरएल में जाना है यूआरएल में देखें इनका
क्या है जो यूजर नाम है इनका यूजर नाम
क्या है ये इनका नाम है
तो मैं अगर मैं बात करता हूं की सीईओ है
और इनका जो यूजर नाम है
यूजर नाम है जो फेसबुक के ऊपर वह क्या है
इनका कंट्रोल
देता हूं कई बार जो यूआरएल में कैसे देखने
को मिलेगा
पर एग्जांपल अगर आपको ऐसे देखने को मिल
रहे हैं एचटीटीपीएस उसके बाद ऐसे और
नेक्स्ट आपको व्यू
facebook.com नेक्स्ट आपको देखने को मिल
रहा है यहां पर प्रोफाइल पी आर ओ एफ आई
प्रोफाइल डॉट एचपी प्रोफाइल डॉट एचपी उसके
बाद आपको देखना होगा स्लैश उसके बाद
क्वेश्चन मार्क उसके बाद आपको देखने को
मिलेगा आईडी और इक्वल तू आपको देखने को
मिलेगा कोई भी रेंडम जैसे की आपको देखने
को मिल जाएगी कोई भी वैल्यू वन तू थ्री
फोर ये ऐसे कोई भी ऐसे वैल्यू देखने को
मिल जाति है इसका मतलब क्या है की जो ये
वैल्यू आपको देखने को मिल रही है ये इसकी
यूजर आईडी है ये इसकी यूजर आईडी है कोई भी
रेंडम आइडिया है तो ये यूजर आईडी से अगर
आपको यूजर नाम फाइंड आउट करना है तो आप
कैसे करोगे यूजर आईडी से आपको अगर यूजर
नाम फाइंड आउट करना है तो आप कैसे करोगे
वो भी फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो या आप यूजर
आईडी भी पता कर सकते हो देखो
अभी मुझे मेरे पास क्या उंगली इनका क्या
है यूजरनेम है मेरे पास तो यूजर आईडी आपको
पता करना है वह भी आप उसके लिए टूल होता
है और यूजर आईडी अगर यहां पर यूजर आईडी शो
हो रही है अभी यहां क्या प्रोफाइल के बड़े
में कुछ ए नहीं रहा इनकी प्रोफाइल्स अगर
मैं चेक करता हूं अबाउट करता हूं देखो
अबाउट यहां पर क्या है शो नहीं कर एक और
तरीका होता है अगर पहले बात तो मैं कम
करता हूं इसको बैक करता हूं और हिट इंटर
करता हूं अभी मेरे पास यूजरनेम है देख टूल
होता है जिसका नाम है मैं आपको लिस्ट ओपन
कर देता हूं
[संगीत]
यहां पर ये रहा आईडी लुक आईडी lookup.com
एक टूल है ये देखिए लीजिए स्क्रीनशॉट ले
लीजिए एचटीटीपीएस
id.com आपको अगर मैं चाट में लिख देता हूं
इसका नाम
लिस्ट प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा लिस्ट प्रोवाइड
कर दूंगा अभी इसका नाम दे देता हूं आपको
क्योंकि आईटी बिल टेक टाइम
डॉट कॉम id.com इस तरीके
क्या बोल रहा है की आपको क्या करना है
यूआरएल टाइप करना है इसमें उसके बाद पर
एग्जांपल मेरे पास क्या है
कंट्रोल
भी कर दिया और यहां पे लुकअप करता हूं
यहां पे आपको देखने को मिलेगा देखो वो
फाउंड ओके
मेरी प्रोफाइल्स है अगर मैं अपनी प्रोफाइल
को होम करता हूं और यह रहा मेरा होम पे
जाता हूं मैं अगर
प्रोफाइल ओपन करता हूं और यहां पर देखो
यहां पर आईडी देखने को मिल रही है अभी मैं
इसको दिखता हूं की इसका मुझे क्या करना है
अगर यूजर नाम फाइंड आउट करना है तो कैसे
करूंगा देखो पहले मैं इसका ओपन करके दिखता
हूं ये आपको आईडी देखो वैसे ही पैरामीटर
आपको देखने को मिलता है प्रोफाइल डॉट एचपी
आईडी इक्वल तू ये
इसका यूजर नाम अगर मुझे पता करना तो मैं
कैसे करूंगा तो मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पर
राइट क्लिक करना है आपको और क्या करना है
आपको व्यू पे सोर्स करना है आपको क्या
करना है
आपके सामने क्या है बहुत सारे कोड ओपन हो
जाएगा आपको कंट्रोल अप करना है फाइंड आउट
करना है तो फाइंड आउट क्या करना है आपको
यहां पे लिखना है
यूजर यूजर वैनिटी वाणी
हिट और करोगे
कंट्रोल करते हैं और कंट्रोल
करते हैं और
कंट्रोल भी करते हैं यहां पर कंट्रोल भी
किया मैंने अब मैं यहां पर करता हूं
कंट्रोल अप उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
यूजरनेटिव
यहां पे देखने को मिल रहा है
यहां पर तो यहां पर क्या है की यूजर आईडी
से आपको यूजर आईडी यहां पर ये देखने को
मिल रही है
जो दिखता हूं आपको ये रही वो यूजर आईडी है
यहां पर
893 399 आपको देखने को जो दिखाई दे रही है
और अगर मैं यहां पे ओपन करता हूं आपको ये
वही यूजर आईडी है यहां पे देखो बिल्कुल से
यूजर आईडी है बट प्रॉब्लम इसे डेट की यहां
पर अगर मैं बात ओके मैंने अब मैं ओपन करता
हूं यहां पर बट क्या की यहां पर इन्होंने
जो यूजर आईडी तो शो कर दिया
इसका मतलब क्या है की इन्होंने यूजर नाम
सेट नहीं किया हुआ है इसके लिए इन्होंने
क्या किया इसके लिए यूजरनेम सेट किया हुआ
नहीं है
इसी तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो उसके भी
यूजर आईडी अगर हमारा टूल कम नहीं कर रहा
है देखो हमारा टूल कम नहीं कर रहा है चलो
हम चलते हैं चलो हमारा टूल कम नहीं कर रहा
है पर एग्जांपल
शायद ये तो मेरा कम नहीं करेगा इस चीज के
लिए ओके ओके
आई डोंट नो की अभी क्यों नहीं कम कर रहा
लुकिंग पर प्रोफाइल
क्या करेंगे राइट क्लिक करेंगे चलो नो और
व्यू पेस्ट हॉर्स करेंगे चलो हम यूपीएससी
उसे करेंगे तो चलो कंट्रोल जो करेंगे और
कंट्रोल सी करेंगे और हम क्या करेंगे यहां
पर पेस्ट कर दें पहले इसको कंट्रोल जो
करेंगे इसको डिलीट कर देंगे कंट्रोल भी कर
देंगे यहां पर उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे
यहां पर यूजर वैनिटी सर्च करेंगे यूजर
वैनिटी हम अब सर्च करेंगे
यूजर आईडी सर्च करेंगे
कॉपी कर लेट हूं कंट्रोल सी करता हूं और
यहां पर क्या करता हूं पेस्ट कर देता हूं
देखो
इनफॉरमेशन कंट्रोल
आपको पता चल गया की किसी की भी यूजर आईडी
कैसे पता कर सकते हो और यूजर आईडी से आपका
कर सकते हो अगर आपके पास उसका यूजर नाम
पता करना तो आप इस तरीके से व्यू पे सर्च
करके यू क्या कर सकते हो आप इनफॉरमेशन देख
सकते हो बट ये तुला भी कई बार क्या होता
है की कौन सा टूल कम कम करेगा
ये तो ओपन जरूर होगा लेकिन टूल कम नहीं कर
नो इशू तो आपको पता चल गया की किसी भी
टारगेट की आप को आईडेंटिफाई आईडेंटिटी अगर
फाइंड आउट करनी है तो आप कैसे कर सकते हैं
अब बात करते हैं की कुछ टूल्स हैं कुछ
टूल्स के लेट मैं आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा
हूं आप स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए एडरवाइज मैं
आई बिल ट्राई मी बेस्ट टीम आपको ग्रुप में
प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा तो ये मेरे को टूल्स की
इनफॉरमेशन है मैं ओपन करता हूं ये टूल से
वन बाय वन है सबसे पहले टूल है आपके पास
एक है की सबसे पहले
इसका यूआरएल क्या है ये रहा https.com
दूसरा टूल है
एचटीटीपीएस इंटेल x.io स्टेप फेसबुक इक्वल
तू फेसबुक
तो सर्च इन्फो उसके बाद एक ये टूल्स आपको
देखने का है कांस्टेंट कंबाइन का डबल्यू
ऑस्टेंट combined.com फेसबुक टूल्स को मैं
एक-एक करके अभी बताता हूं देखो पहले टूल
के बड़े में आपको पता चल गया अब ये जो टूल
है देखो क्या है इसके अंदर मल्टीपल टूल्स
इसके अंदर आपके पास मल्टीप्लेक्स टूल्स
हैं तो यहां भी हम क्या कर सकते हैं आईडी
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं यूआईडी तो एक कम कर
हमारे पास क्या था यूआरएल कौन सा था ये
इनका मापन करता हूं यार मार्क्स जगह पर ये
रहा कंट्रोल सी करता हूं अब देखते हैं की
क्या ये भी टूल कम नहीं करेगा क्या
देखते अभी सबसे पहले गेट आईडी यहां से हम
क्या करते हैं आईडी पता कर सकते हैं और
फाइंड आउट फाइंड करते हैं यहां पर
सामने फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश कर रहा है
आईडी का वही तरीका बैक गया तो हमने बताया
आपको ऐसे पता करने के लिए उसके बाद आपको
थर्ड ऑप्शन देखने को मिल रहा है सर्च यहां
पर क्या का सकते हो काफी एक प्रकार से
क्या काफी एडवांस सबसे है क्या की वो सारे
सर्च क्या कर सकते हो आप उसके अंदर सर्च
नहीं कर सकते फेसबुक के सर्च इंजन के थ्रू
लेकिन इस टूल के थ्रू आप कर सकते हो पर
एग्जांपल आप क्या कर सकते हो यहां पर सर्च
स्पेसिफिक दे आपने क्या लिखा के शब्द में
मैंने लिखा मार्क चक्रवर्ती जूस के लिखा
जब चक्कर बैंड किया मैंने जे यू सी के ये
आर बी आई आर जी मार्क जुकरबर्ग किया मैंने
यहां पर कोई भी मैंने क्या कर दिया डेट
दाल दी रेंडम डेट दाल दी कोई भी पर
एग्जांपल मैं यहां पर कर दिया इसके साथ अब
ये क्या करेगा सर्च करेगा फेसबुक के दिस
पेज इसे नोट अवेलेबल
ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके
हम एक कम करते हैं इस यूआरएल को ओपन करते
हैं कंट्रोल सी इसी के अंदर ओपन कर दें
अभी एक बार वो जो हमारे पास ये वाला था
कंट्रोल भी करते हैं
क्या हो सकता है
[संगीत]
कंट्रोल सी और वह करेगा
23 जून जून 28 अप्रैल जनवरी
कोई भी डेट एड कर देते हैं 123 और सर्च
करते हैं
देखो अभी देखो सर्च कैसे करेगा अभी क्या
इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल रही है ओके ओके
सर्च ओके देखो ये देखो
सर्च किया और अगर यहां पर देखोगे डेट
पोस्टेड यहां पर क्या वैसे आप इसके बेसिस
पर सर्च
कर सकते लेकिन पार्टिकल रेट आपसे सिलेक्ट
नहीं कर सकते अभी देखो सेकंड जनवरी की
जितनी भी पोस्ट थी ये साड़ी की साड़ी इसने
शो कर दी इस तरीके से ये इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग कर पाओगे इसकी हेल्प से नेक्स्ट
क्या है नेक्स्ट ऑप्शन उसे कर सकते हो
आप सर्च कर सकते हो स्पेसिफिक मठ के बेस
पे भी क्या कर सकते हो आप सर्च कर सकते हो
मैंने
जे यू सी के ए आर बी ए आर जी
स्पेसिफिक मठ मैंने क्या किया फरवरी 23
उसके बाद सर्च किया अभी देखो और 23 की
जितनी पोस्ट संग थी जो भी उन्होंने किया
होगा वो साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल
जाएगी देखो काफी इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को
मिले टारगेट के बड़े में देखो मां से करवा
हैप्पी बर्थडे तू मी फेवरेट परसों और मी
अगस्त लाइक ये देखो तो काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है
15 एयर हो गए मास है पीपल तू हॉवर्ड रंग
ये देखो तो ये साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने
को मिल जाएगी
आप सर्च कर सकते हो उसके बाद देखो जितने
भी मैंने आपको बताया था इस तरीके आप कर
सकते हो देखो टूल को उसे करना आपको खुद से
ही सीखना होगा हर कोई आपको पूरा टूल उसे
करना नहीं शिखा सकता उसके बाद देखिए
स्पेसिफिक यहां पर क्या कर सकते हो के
शब्द है एड करोगे मार्क किया मैंने मार
उसके बाद क्या किया मैंने मार और कब से कब
तक मैंने क्या किया की मैं सर्च करना
चाहता हूं
अगर याद ए रहा है तो वही वाली चीज है देखो
यहां पर अंटील और साइंस वाली इसमें यहां
पर स्टॉल के थ्रू हम कर का रहे हैं देखो
ये साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिल रहा
है अरे यार छोड़ो छोड़ो मार्केट
सॉरी सॉरी पर था ओके
पैसे कर सकते हो अगर आपके पास एक चीज बताओ
देखो अगर आपको लोकेशंस की बेस पे करना
देखो लोकेशन मेरे पास क्या है पर एग्जांपल
मार्क मैंने लिखा मार्ग
उसके बाद क्या है लोकेशन अब यहां पर क्या
करना है आपको लोकेशन की यूआईडी यहां पर
पुटिंग करनी है आप लोकेशन की आईडी आपको
कैसे पता चलेगा ये इनके प्रोफाइल्स है अब
ये देखो यहां पर क्लिक करोगे ना ये रहा ये
इनका लोकेशन देखो फ्रॉम ये है और लाइव सीन
पालो ऑटो कैलिफोर्निया यहां पर मैंने
क्लिक किया जब मैंने इसके ऊपर क्लिक
करूंगा मैं देखो मैं इसके ऊपर क्या करता
हूं हां ये रहा में जब इसके ऊपर क्लिक
किया तो मैंने यहां पर क्या किया मैंने
व्यू पे सोर्स किया है जब मैंने यहां पर
व्यू पेज सोर्स किया तो मैं आपको क्या
करूंगा
एक मिनट एक मिनट एक मिनट मुझे पीएस सर्च
करने की वजह से नहीं थी क्योंकि यूपीएससी
को नहीं जरूर नहीं है क्योंकि आपको यहां
पर देखने को मिलती देखो यहां पर आईडी
देखने को भी ये वो आईडी आपके लोकेशन आईडी
यहां पर यहां पर वो लोकेशन आईडी देखने को
मिल रही है मैं यहां पर क्या आपको पी उसके
बाद मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पर पेस्ट कर
देता हूं पेस्ट और सर्च कर देता हूं अब ये
क्या करेगा देखो इसी लोकेशन आईडी के साथ
आपकी साड़ी पोस्ट को सर्च करके देख रहे थे
दिखा देगा देखो यहां पर देखो पोस्ट फ्रॉम
पलवल तू कैलिफोर्निया देखो यहां पर ये
देखिए ये रही ये साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन आपको
देखने को मिल रहे होगी इस तरीके से कर
सकते हो
तो देखो एक टूल के बड़े में बता दे रहा
हूं जितने भी टूल्स हैं जितने भी टूल्स
आपके सामने मैं शो हो गया सारे सिमिलर कम
करते हैं बिल्कुल सिमिलर क्योंकि क्या
होता है ना की आपके पास जितनी ज्यादा
टूल्स होंगे ना हो सकता की एक टूल कम ना
करें दूसरा टूल आपके साथ कम करेगा ही
करेगा अब इसके बाद क्या आपको पता चल गया
अब यहां पे ये क्या है पोस्ट डायरेक्टली
फ्रॉम यहां पे क्या है की पोस्ट फ्रॉम किस
से जाते हो पोस्ट फ्रॉम यहां पर यूआईडी आप
मेंशन कर सकते हो किसकी चक्रवर्ती या 4 है
और केवल क्या सर्च करना चाहता हूं मैं
क्या करना चाहता हूं मेटा और इसके बाद
सर्च कर सकता हूं तो देखो
देखने को मिल जाएगी तो आप इस तरीके से इस
टूल को उसे कर सकते हो उसके बाद क्या किया
इंस्टाग्राम पोस्ट ऑन डेट
इंस्टाग्राम यूआरएल दे सकते हो उसके बाद
ऑन डेटेड के बेसिस यहां पे क्या कर सकते
हो डेट दे सकते हो तो एक ही टूल को उसे
करना सिख सकते हो ऐसे उसके बाद नेक्स्ट
अगला टूल के लिस्ट में चलते हैं हम दूसरा
टूल कौन सा हमारा ये रहा दूसरा टूल एक टूल
हो गया हमारे पास हूं पोस्टेड vaat.com
नेक्स्ट आपका इंटेल इंटेल आई अलसो ईमेल से
है देखो पोस्ट यहां पर केवल सर्च करना है
यहां पर डेट इस की तरह सिमिलर कम कर रहा
है नेक्स्ट है 14 पोस्ट इन पर्टिकुलर मंथ
यहां पर केवल डॉग मां सिलेक्ट करोगे लाइक
डेट से है पोस्ट इन इंटरवल इंटरवल फ्रॉम
और तू देखोगे उसके बाद पोस्ट फ्रॉम सम वन
पोस्टिंग अबाउट समथिंग यहां पर आईडी मेंशन
करोगे कीबोर्ड उसके बाद सर्च करोगे
एक चीज प्रॉब्लम आपको
अपने तरीके से कम करता है पर एग्जांपल
कैसे सोएगा आपको देखो ये रिजल्ट ऐसे शो
करेगा अभी ये क्या है पेज नोट फाउंड
क्योंकि लॉगिन ओके नो इशू अब आईडी नहीं
चलो इसके बेस पर शो नहीं कर रहा हूं देखिए
इसमें लॉगिन करना पड़ेगा ओके हमें क्या
करना पड़ेगा इसके अंदर लॉगिन करना पड़ेगा
इसके अंदर लॉगिन करना पड़ेगा मैं कम करता
हूं लॉगिन करके दिखता हूं क्योंकि मेरे
पास ऑलरेडी लॉगिन है तो मैं ओपन करता हूं
इधर और मैं पर एग्जांपल मेरे पास ये है
इंटेक्स का क्योंकि लोग इन करना पड़ेगा
आपको जब ये रिजल्ट आपको शो करेगा और जब
हमें यूआईडी 4 है मेरे पास और मैं का रहा
हूं ये वाला मेहता कर रहा हूं इसके बाद
सर्च करता हूं देखो अभी लोग इन फेसबुक
ऑलरेडी लॉगिन है
ओके ओके ओके
चलो ये आपको लॉगिन करना पड़ेगा तो वैसे
चाहे तो आप खुद से भी ट्राई कर सकते हो तो
अभी मैं क्या करता हूं लॉगिन मुझे यहां पर
करना पड़ेगा एक मिनट और यहां पर
देखो मैंने यहां पर लॉगिन कर दिया देखो यह
इस तरीके से शो करता है इसका अपना अपना
रिजल्ट शो करने का तरीका देखो इसका क्या
जो इंटरफेस है आउटपुट शो करेगा ये इस
तरीका देखो जो पोस्ट देखो ये इस तरीके से
पोस्ट करेगा पीपल ये इस तरीके से शो करने
वाला है देखो ये अपने तरीके से शो करता है
तो आपको अपना सब का होता है तो अब मैं
क्या कहता है बैक करता हूं उसके बाद फिर
से बैक करता हूं
चलो बैक करता हूं उसके बाद अरे इसमें तो
क्या पूरा इसी को ओपन कर दिया नो एक कम कर
दे हम इसको आउट कहां से कर सकते हैं भैया
इसको क्या करता हूं लोग आउट कर देता हूं
भैया मेरे मेरी प्रोफाइल को पकड़ दो
अभी मैंने क्या कर दिया तो इस तरीके से
क्या है इंटेल एक्स कम करता है इसमें एक
और चीज है देखो
एक और है ग्राफ स्कैनर की तरह
इसमें भी एडवांस है पोस्ट सर्च किया यहां
पर क्या करोगे पोस्ट फ्रॉम पब्लिक नीड्स
तो किया यहां पर क्या करना पड़ेगा आपको
कीवर्ड एड करना पड़ेगा एड करने के लिए
आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा यहां पर क्या करोगे
और के शब्द का नाम लिखा मैंने बेटा उसके
बाद मैंने किया मटर उसके बाद क्या कर दिया
यहां पर वो क्या कर दिया ये शब्द एड कर
दिया मैंने तो यहां पर क्या करें हो जाएगा
उसके बाद पर एग्जांपल आपको क्या करना है
पोस्ट फ्रॉम पोस्ट तू स्पेसिफाई यहां पर
आपको क्या है आईडी पर एग्जांपल पोस्ट
फ्रॉम पोस्ट फ्रॉम स्पेसिफाई एंटी मैंने
फोर किया तो इसको आप क्या करो एड कर डॉग
तो ऑथर एड कर देंगे यहां पर ये फोर हो गया
इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो टैग
लोकेशन लोकेशन की अगर आपके पास होगी कुछ
आइडिया नहीं मैंने लोकेशन एड कर दी उसके
बाद यहां पर क्या करना फिल्टर डेट तो उसके
बाद क्या करें जैसे ही आप क्या करोगे यहां
पर तो यूआरएल ओपन योर न्यू विंडो तो ये
क्या करेगा काफी और भी
आपको शो करेगा तो इस तरीके से क्या ये
इंटेलिजेंस एक्स का कम करता है
नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं हम ये रहा फेसबुक
टिप्स बेटा वाला इसमें क्या है इसमें भी
ऑप्शन है पोस्ट पीपल फोटोस पेज प्लेस इस
वीडियो एवं स्टॉप इनके बेस पर मैं
पोस्ट करता हूं देखो
इसमें मैं क्या करता हूं अगर मैं एड करता
हूं
यूआरएल भाई के शब्द मैं क्या करता हूं
कीवर्ड मैंने सर्च किया की माता की
सर्च कर दिया मैंने यहां पर और एड कर दिया
ठीक है यहां पर एड हो गया उसके बाद मैं का
रहा हूं आईडी और कर दी मैंने आईडी तो
लोकेशन मैंने क्या कर दिया यहां पर पेस्ट
कर दिया पर एग्जांपल एड कर दिया नेक्स्ट
यहां पर क्या है टारगेट में 2020 से लेकर
मठ कौन सा है फरवरी
क्या है
लेकिन उसके बाद
मैंने इसको भी एड कर दिया उसके बाद क्या
ओपन
नहीं होगा
हर चीज के लिए मुझे क्या करना लॉगिन करना
जब मैं एक बार लॉगिन कर डन
आपको खुद से करके देखना है क्योंकि मैं
बार-बार लॉगिन करता हूं तो फिर बार-बार
लोग आउट भी करना पड़ेगा तो इस तरीके से
फिल्टर कम करता है तो एक ये फिल्टर आपके
सामने पता चल गया एक और फिल्टर है एक एक
और तरीका ये रहा ये भी से है ये क्या है
यहां पर क्या से पोस्ट पीपल लगे है अगर
मैं इवेंट का तो देखो ये इसी तरीके से
आपके सामने और पुरुष शो करेगा
एक
टूल है ये भी काफी इंटरेस्टिंग बोल रहा है
काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन आपको प्रोवाइड करता है
तो ये सारे क्या है एक एक से
एक से एक आपको देखने को मिल जाएंगे यह
सारे टूल्स एक्सरसाइज
आपको देखने को मिल जा रही है तो आपको पता
चल रहा होगा अभी जैसे की ये रहा मैं आपको
दिखता हूं देखो इसमें तीन ऑप्शन देखने को
मिलते हैं आपको कौन से तीन ऑप्शन क्या
देखने को मिल रहा है आपको यहां पर तीन
ऑप्शंस आपको देखने को मिल रहे हैं तीन
ऑप्शन के अनुसार मल्टिस म्युचुअल फ्रेंड्स
यहां पर क्या होता है की आप अपने टारगेट
की यूजर आईडी प्रोवाइड करोगे अगर आपके पास
फ्रेंड्स की वैरायटी है कोई भी फ्रेंड्स
आपका म्युचुअल फ्रेंड्स है कोई भी आपको
लगा की ये इसका फ्रेंड हो सकता है उसकी
आईडी प्रोवाइड करोगे क्या करेगा एक लिस्ट
फाइंड आउट करके दे देगा दोनों की फ्रेंड
लिस्ट की आपको प्रोडक्ट लेकिन क्या है की
ये टूल अभी इसको एकदम ये जो फर्स्ट ऑप्शन
है ना ये अभी जो अपडेट हुआ है लेटेस्ट
अपडेट हुआ है फेसबुक का उसके साथ ये कम
नहीं करता मैंने इसको पैच कर दिया है तो
ये अभी कम नहीं करता है लेकिन ये रहा
मल्टीपल कीवर्ड्स सर्च उन्हें प्रोफाइल
पेज और ग्रुप ये कम करता है यहां पर
एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया प्रमोशन किया
पसंद सिलेक्शन किया इसके बाद में टारगेट
पसंद
करना चाहता हूं बी आई आर टी हा भरदे सर्च
करना चाहता हूं उसके बाद मैं क्या सर्च
करना चाहता हूं
रिलेशनशिप आज
इसके साथ सर्च करना चाहता हूं और मैं सर्च
करता हूं और ये देखो ये मल्टेबल स्टेप्स
में ओपन करें अब हर चीज के लिए मुझे क्या
करना पड़ेगा लॉगिन करना पड़ेगा इसके लिए
लॉगिन हर एक चीज के लिए मुझे क्या करना
पड़ेगा लॉगिन करना चाहूंगा लॉगिन करूंगा
तभी ये कम करेगा बट मैं अभी लॉगिन नहीं
करने वाला तो हम इसको कट कर देता हूं जब
आप लॉगिन करोगे तो कम करेगा क्योंकि आपके
पास फेक आईडी हो कुछ भी हो आपको इस के
क्योंकि आपको लॉगिन नहीं करना पड़ा तभी
आउटपुट आपको शो कर रहा है तो ये इस तरीके
से कम करता है परसों की जगह पेज सिलेक्ट
कर सकते हो पेज की जगह फिर क्या कर सकते
हो ग्रुप सिलेक्ट कर सकते हो उसके बाद
मल्टीपल के शब्द को भी सर्च कर सकते हो
फोटोस के लिए यहां पर क्या लिस्ट ऑफ केवट
लिखिए उसके बाद क्या फाइंड फोटो यूजिंग
मल्टीपल की और फिर भी क्या है इसके लिए
आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा लॉगिन करना पड़ेगा
आपके फेसबुक अकाउंट के अंदर अभी यह कम
करेगा
तो मुझे एक चीज बताइए जितने भी टूल्स का
नाम मैंने आपको बताया जितने भी टूल्स आपके
सामने स्क्रीन पर मैंने शो किया सभी को
समझ में आया है एक्चुअल में कैसे कम कर
रहे हैं क्योंकि आपके सर्च इंजन के साथ वो
किस हाथी कम कर रहे हैं आप अलग से कुछ
नहीं कर रहे लेकिन आपके सर्च इंजन के साथ
ही कम पर है जब भी एक कम करोगे जब भी आप
इन टूल्स को उसे करोगे जब भी आप इंटूल्स
को किसी को भी आप फिल्टर करने का टूल को
उसे करते हो तो आपको क्या करना जब भी हो
ओके ओके जब टूल्स को उसे करते हैं ना आप
तो टूल उसे करने के बाद क्या आएगी वो आपके
फेसबुक प्रोफाइल पर रीडायरेक्ट करता है और
किसके साथ इस आईडी के साथ ये आइडिया सर्च
कर रहे थे
वगैरा इसी आईडी के साथ क्या करता है यह सच
करता है तो आपको फिर एक चीज ध्यान रखना है
जब भी आकर तो रिलेटिव सर्च में जाना ही
जाना है आपको लेट यूजर्स के बेसिस पे भी
आपको इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करनी है रिलेटिव
सब्सक्राइबर को क्या करना है इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग करने ही करनी है देखो एक चीज
ध्यान रखना जब भी हम ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस
करते हैं ना उसमें हम ब्लैक हेड्स हैंड से
ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस करते हैं क्योंकि जब
तक हम ब्लैक है ब्लैक है हैकर मन के साथ
हम ओपन डाइजेस्ट नहीं करेंगे तो हम क्या
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग नहीं कर पाएंगे बट वे
आर डी एथिकल हैकर्स इसलिए हम क्या है की
हमें पता है की लीगल क्या है क्या इलीगल
है तो हमें क्या है की सारे कम लिख ली
करने हैं विदाउट परमिशन कुछ भी परफॉर्म
नहीं करनी है फरदर स्टेप में लेकिन क्या
है की जब मैं आपके पास परमीशंस है कम करने
की तो आप क्या करते हो जो भी ओपन सोशल
ट्रेड जिनके स्टेप परफॉर्म करते हैं वो
क्या करते हो आप मन सेट आपका ब्लैक है
वाला होता है लेकिन क्या है आप एथिकल हैकर
सी होते हैं जो क्या करते हो आप उन चीजों
को फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं और
एक चीज ध्यान रखना की आप जो भी करो जितने
भी आप सर्चिंग कम कर रहे हो ऐसा सवाल के
साथ जितने भी पॉसिबल आपको कीवर्ड्स मिलते
हैं इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग के सारे नोट ऑन करो
जितने भी पॉसिबल आपको लगता है की यह
कीवर्ड भी सर्जिकल में भी सर्च कर लो सर्च
कर लो हो सकता है कहानी ना कहानी आपको कोई
ना कोई ऐसी इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल जाए जो
काफी कम की हो क्योंकि हमेशा एक चीज ध्यान
रखना की एक छोटी सी भी इनफॉरमेशन है स्मॉल
बीट ऑफ इनफॉरमेशन काफी हेल्प कर शक्ति है
बड़े-बड़े सिस्टम को कंप्रोमाइज करने के
लिए तो आपका कम क्या है की जो स्मॉल बीट
ऑफ इनफॉरमेशन
कर पाओगे आप क्या कर सकते हो किसी भी बड़े
से बड़े सिस्टम को इजीली कंप्रोमाइज कर
पाओगे अभी क्या है की हम सेशन और करते हैं
क्योंकि अभी कुछ
आधा हो गया हमारा फेसबुक ओपन सोशल
टेलिजेंस का ज्यादा कुछ बच्चा नहीं है और
की टूल्स के बड़े में बता चुका हूं हां एक
चीज है की अगर आपको जानना है की
देखो मैंने क्या बताया की यह टूल्स है जो
तू जो भी टूल्स है
वैसे
भी टूल्स को क्या चाहिए
लोकेशन आईडी चाहिए होती है ग्रुप आईडी
चाहिए होती है इवेंट आईडी चाहिए होती है
तो ये साड़ी आईडी कैसे निकलते है कोई
एग्जांपल मैंने क्या बताया आपको यूजर आईडी
कैसे निकलेगी आपको पता है क्योंकि ये
मार्क्स अगर मैंने क्योंकि सर्च किया है
अगर यूजर आईडी में कम करता हूं इसको ये
मार्क जुकरबर्ग है ये मेरी प्रोफाइल है तो
यूजर आईडी तो आपको पता चल गया की कैसे
निकाल सकते हैं एग्जांपल आपको क्या करना
है लोकेशन आईडी आपको पता है की अगर देखो
ठीक है आपने यहां पर क्लिक किया राइट
क्लिक किया ओपन न्यू तब किया यहां पर आपको
देखने को मिल गई ये लोकेशन मिल रही है
देखने को नहीं मिलेगा आपको क्या करना है
राइट क्लिक करना है व्यूज करना है और
कंट्रोल करना है कंट्रोल सी करना है
कंट्रोल जो
डिलीट
कर देना है उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है
यहां पर
यहां पर सर्च करना आपको जब भी आप क्या कर
सकते हो खासकर
ये ओनली ये तो आपको देखने को मिलेगा ही
मिलेगा
सर्च कर रहा हूं मैं यहां पर थिंग्स मैं 1
मिनट
क्या हो गया
ओके
व्हाट हैपन यार
आपको पता है यहां पर क्या करना सर्च करना
है आपको थिंग्स तू डू इन सर्च करोगे
इनफॉरमेशन देखो
सिस्टम गो हैंग
चलो
सी करना है कंट्रोल भी करना वापस कंट्रोल
मेरे भाई
मेरे भाई क्लोज क्लोज
मेरे हाथ में कुछ नहीं अभी इसके बाद मैं
क्या कल बता दूंगा की मैं आपको क्या कहा
कल बता दूंगा तो इसे कोई डाउट हो तो आप
पूछ सकते हैं
और फिर से अगर आपको सेशन अच्छा लगे तो
प्लीज लाइक सब्सक्राइब कमेंट करना मत
भूलिए लेकिन हालांकि वो आप करते नहीं हो
तो कोई सुनिए
अभी लाइफ में आप खुद भी ऐसे कुछ कम करने
सोचोगे ना तो जब आपको लाइक कमेंट नहीं
मिलेंगे तो आपको भी पता चल जाएगा की जब
हमने किसी के लाइक कमेंट नहीं की तो तुम
दूसरों से क्या उम्मीद कर सकते हो
और करेंगे लेकिन आपके लिए 5 मिनट पर डाउट
क्षेत्र अगर किसी को कोई डाउट हो आज के
सेशन रिलेटेड पूछ सकता है
कोई भी डाउट है तो वो पूछ सकता है एडरवाइज
सेशन को क्या करेंगे और करेंगे
नो कल भी आपका सेशन होगा
कल भी आपका सेशन होगा
[संगीत]